Hold around the world is marijuana is being decriminalized or even made legal,
but is this really a good idea?
In the online debate,
the harmful sites are often downplayed,
so let's look at the three most powerful arguments against legalizing marijuana
argument.
Number one,
in the last few decades,
marijuana has been engineered to become much more potent.
Today,
marijuana is so potent that it's actually a strong drug that may cause
psychosis.
The main active ingredient of marijuana is THC,
and there's strong evidence that THC is related to psychosis regardless of other
risk factors.
Marijuana also contains a substance called CBD that seems to counteract for as a
fax.
It's even being tested as a treatment against psychosis and anxiety,
but because it doesn't make you high,
growers have gradually decreased the amount of CBD in marijuana of the last few
decades while increasing THC levels.
Sample testing showed the THC levels have risen from around 4% in the 1990s to
nearly 12% in 2014 shifting the ratio of THC to CBD from one to 14 in 1995 to
about one two 80 and 2014 it's unclear how precise those tests were.
However,
overall recent findings suggest that the more marijuana you consume and the
stronger it is,
the higher your risk of developing psychosis.
But how high is the risk of psychosis for the general population?
A study from Brett and found that while marijuana use has risen significantly
between 1996 and 2005 the number of schizophrenia cases a type of psychosis
remain stable.
The risk of marijuana and juice psychosis remains the highest for people who
already have a high risk of psychosis to begin with.
For them,
it seems more lifey that marijuana speeds up the development of their condition
rather than causing it.
As far as we know right now,
so the reasoning goes,
if fewer people have access to marijuana,
the lower the risk of marijuana and juice psychosis.
But actually you could argue that precisely because marijuana is illegal,
more people will end up with psychosis.
Prohibition makes a legal drug stronger and more potions because this way you
can ship more product in a smaller space and sell it at a greater profits.
This is what happened during the Prohibition of alcohol and the u s where hard
liquor became the norm and the same is happening with marijuana.
Now imagine a world where liquor is the only alcohol available.
You have the choice of either not drinking at all or getting much drunker than
you would like to.
This is the situation for many marijuana smokers today.
People didn't stop drinking during prohibition and the numbers show that laws
don't deter people from using marijuana.
We can't make marijuana go away,
but we can make it safer.
If marijuana were legal,
there would be more options for consumers and regulators could,
for example,
insist on a high level of CBD,
just like most people don't drink and after work bottle of vodka,
many people would gladly consume the after work beer version of marijuana.
Argument to marijuana is a gateway drug.
If it's legalized,
there will be a spike in the use of much more dangerous drugs.
A 2015 study found that about 45% of lifelong marijuana users took some other
illegal drug.
At some point,
legalizing marijuana could reinforce this trend.
As more young people try legal marijuana,
they might end up trying harder drugs,
but it turns out that the real gateway to drug use comes much ellia cigarettes.
One study showed the teens who started smoking before the age of 15 we're 80%
more likely to use illegal drugs than those who didn't.
And a 2007 study found that teenagers between 12 and 17 who smoked with three
times more likely to binge drink,
seven times more likely to have used drugs like heroin or cocaine.
And we're also seven times more likely to resort to marijuana.
But if that's the case,
how could making more drugs legal stomp the use of hard drugs?
At first,
it's important to acknowledge that people don't use drugs because that legal or
not,
if you want to buy any drug,
you'll always find someone happy to sell.
The real question is why do people develop an unhealthy relationship with drugs
at all?
Studies show that set conditions make people especially vulnerable to drugs and
addiction,
a difficult childhood,
early trauma,
low social status,
depression,
even genetic factors,
which drug they get addicted to is more often than not a matter of chance.
Addicts take drugs to escape that problems,
but drugs don't solve any of those problems and instead become a new problem,
but punishing people for that unhealthy coping mechanisms.
It doesn't change anything about the underlying causes either.
So some argue we need to take a completely different route and 2001 Portugal had
one of the worst drug problems in Europe,
so it was desperate enough to try something.
Radical possession and use of all illegal drugs was decriminalized.
You would no longer be arrested.
Instead,
or authorities launched a major health campaign,
people who were found with a small amount,
we're referred to support services and got help with treatment and harm
reduction.
Drug use was seen as a chronic disease,
not a crime.
The results were stunning.
The number of people who try drugs and kept using them fell from 44% to 8% by
2012 the use of hard drugs decreased as what?
As HIV and hepatitis infections and overdoses making drugs legal might overall
helps society much more than it harms it.
Argument number three,
marijuana is addictive and unhealthy.
It needs to remain illegal to keep harm at a minimum.
While marijuana addiction is more psychological than physical,
it is still a real problem.
The demand for treatment for marijuana addiction has more than doubled in the
past decade alone and total about 10% of people who try marijuana will become
addicted.
This is also related to higher THC levels.
A study released in 2017 track the potency of marijuana and Dutch coffee shops
over a period of 16 years for every 1% increase in THC,
60 more people and to treatment nationwide.
In terms of negative health effects,
some studies linked marijuana use to increase blood pressure and lung problems.
While a 2016 study found that marijuana use was unrelated to physical health
problems except for a high risk of gum disease.
Some studies show that marijuana use auteurs teenagers brains and decreases
their intelligence,
but when more recent studies took drinking and smoking into account,
the results were inconclusive.
Overall,
research shows that taking any drugs while the brain is still in development is
bad for you,
but the truth is we don't know yet how unhealthy marijuana res,
we need more funding for research,
which is hard to get.
While marijuana remains illegal.
We can put what we know into perspective though 16% of people who consume
alcohol become alcoholics and 32% of people who try cigarettes become smokers.
We know for sure alcohol affects your brain,
destroys your liver,
and causes cancer.
While tobacco clogs your arteries,
destroys your lungs,
and also causes cancer.
3.3 million people die from alcohol abuse each chair,
while smoking kills more than 6 million people.
Nobody is suggesting tobacco and alcohol or harm.
This just because their legal.
Also,
nobody is seriously proposing to prohibit them even though they are extremely
dangerous.
The Gannett is a way to exercise some control over them,
especially when it comes to protecting young people.
It's often much harder to buy legal drugs for teenagers than to buy illegal
ones.
Official sellers can get hefty fines and lose their license if they sell to
underage kids legality and creates incentives.
Here the drug dealers can't exploit.
So making marijuana legal doesn't mean in dosing it.
It means taking responsibility for the risks that poses.
It could also open the floodgates to tons of new research that shows us how
harmful it really is and to whom
conclusion,
marijuana is a drug and just like any other drug,
it has negative consequences for a sizable portion of the people who use it is
he is not harmless.
The best way to protect society from its negative consequences seems to be
legalization and regulation,
thanks to our partnership with [inaudible] has already been available on our
German channel for two weeks.
Check it out and subscribe to practice your German skills.
And if you want to support the creation of videos that take months to research a
repat and get a bunch of cool stuff in return,
you can do that on patrion.com/cuts cause art.